quelle rencontre c'est drôle parce que
pour la première fois parce que je
regarde jamais ces trucs à et revoyant
le clip de 1,2 sous le vent j'ai une
belle revanche pas très représentative
ou céline était en fait l'avion qui fait
monter le
planeur et elle voulait m'amener très
haut
puis un moment c'est presque moi qui a
coupé le cordon corse dont un peu le
cordon pour me laisser planer parce que
j'avais envie plus de descendre que de
monter je voulais pas devenir le
chanteur le jeu l'est pas être partout
sur la planète tu voulais pas
non gia émis un moment où il y avait une
limite où je voulais pas aller plus haut
et pas par part mais justin ma part je
me disais quand on va au dessus des
nuages des moments où ça se ressent
forcément et je préfère avoir démonté
puis descendre avec le pleure parce
qu'elle avait plus belle piste est
arrivé au bord d'un lac ou ce mois là
quand ma vie c'est plus comme ça vous
êtes resté proche du céline dion chez
rester on était très proches avec céline
puis c'est vrai que l je pense qu'elle
n'a pas compris quand j'ai quand j'ai
coupé les ponts avec eux et quand on se
retrouve c'est magique parce que plein
de choses qui se passent dans nos yeux
parce que
cette compétition est une véritable
connexion ou des choses qu'elle a osé
pas dire
aux autres mais déjà parce que on
faisait le même métier parce qu'on était
deux petits diamants bruts québécois et
parce que aussi essayer de comprendre ma
vision et moi la sienne dont elle avait
complicité unique et
est heureux ici j'aime raison quelque
part d'avoir trahi quelque chose mais en
même temps je sais que comprend que je
suis un jeu reste un animal sauvage